starting with 10 electors on Monday we
then had 29 electors yesterday and then
40 electors and now there are over 50
electors nearly ten percent of the total
electorate demanding a full briefing on
Russian interference in the 2016
presidential election before they
officially cast their electoral ballots
on Monday December nineteenth and these
now it again started with ten and now it
is more than 50 electors that's that's
ten percent of the electorate they are
putting pressure on the Director of
National Intelligence James clapper to
tell us more tell them more about what
the CIA knows about how they reach the
conclusion that indeed Russian
involvement helped Donald Trump win the
election electoral e by 58 thousand
votes in three states on november eighth
this is uh all Democratic electors plot
press + Chrissa prune who is that
Republican electorate has gone public in
saying that he is a Republican elector
who will not vote for Donald Trump on
December nineteenth up from the letter
that these electors have signed and sent
to the Director of National Intelligence
quote the electors require to know from
the intelligence community whether there
are in ongoing investigations into ties
between Donald Trump his campaign or
associates and Russian government
interference in the election the scope
of those investigations how far those
investigations may have reached and who
was involved in those investigations we
require we further require a briefing on
all investigative findings as these
matters directly impact the core factors
in our deliberations of whether mr.
Trump is fit to serve as president of
the United States translated if Russia
help Trump win that changes what our
votes maybe or what our votes should be
on December nineteenth now the Hillary
Clinton campaign has also added its name
in support of this effort this is of no
importance to a ton of Trump voters who
two years ago would have one hundred
percent agreed with Mitt Romney's
statement that Russia and Vladimir Putin
are our greatest geo political foes all
of a sudden all these right-wingers seem
completely unconcerned
with Russia I will guarantee you that
the CIA could find concrete evidence
that Trump colluded with Putin himself
to win this election and they would
shout out that the CIA just doesn't know
what it's talking about and I want to
follow up on one thing because there
have been a lot of Trumpets who after
the CIA came out and said we've
determined that Russia was involved
specifically to help Donald Trump the
trumpets have found it popular or or
pleasing in some way to say this is the
same CIA that got it wrong and said Iraq
had weapons of mass destruction let me
remind you the CIA did not say Saddam
Hussein has weapons of mass destruction
the Bush administration pumped up and
exaggerated what the CIA had actually
said about Saddam and weapons of mass
destruction to make the case that Saddam
had weapons of mass destruction Colin
Powell was guilty of this Condoleezza
Rice was involved in this dick cheney
george w bush but that mean that now is
circulating that oh we can't believe the
CIA because they're the same ones who
told us beyond a reasonable doubt Iraq
has weapons of mass destruction before
that invasion that is absolutely just
not true now one other rationalization
I've been starting to see in the
recesses of the right wing websites and
comment cesspools is that actually the
alliance between the US and Russia
really what they mean is Trump and Putin
is good because at its core Russia is a
good Christian nation that accepts Jesus
and that we should be friends
fascinating I mean you might as well
come out and say you know of Putin's
also really alpha or something that we
would expect to hear from the all right
bottom line six days to go until the
electors actually vote pretty unlikely
that there's going to be any real
briefing of substance Republican
electors are not really jumping on board
in demanding this briefing and we have
every indication that Vladimir is going
to get his White House lap dog his
violin that he'll be playing for at
least four years and there's not too too
much than anybody can do about it but we
are all aware that Donald Trump will be
the weakest president that we have had
in a very long time losing the popular
vote by more than
% mounting evidence that a foreign power
with significant ties to the
president-elect put a finger on the
electoral scale and helped him win and
what's being ignored here is that if
Russia did hack to help Trump they did
it for a reason and that's not really
being discussed much in this sort of two
main possibilities in both are bad one
Russia saw a trump win as embarrassing
to the USA in a way that would allow
Russia to be seen as better smarter more
powerful or more respectable I'm leaning
sort of less in that direction option
two is Russia wanted Trump to win
because they see Trump is actually being
good for them and I'm leaning more and
more in this direction particularly now
that we've seen Russia friendly oil CEO
Rex Tillerson named as the Secretary of
State every indication that if indeed
Russia was involved to help Donald Trump
it was specifically because they
believed that it would be good for them
and Donald Trump's cabinet pics are
certainly bolstering that that
hypothesis big league don't battle the
crowds and stand in line and get into
insane arguments with people over who
was waiting for the parking spot in the
mall parking lot first whether it's
Hanukkah shopping or Christmas shopping
or Kwanzaa shopping or festivus shopping
i believe december twenty third this
year is the amazing celebration a
festivus they're all only a couple of
weeks away and you can go to shari's
berries at Barry's dot-com you can
choose berries dipped in white chocolate
dipped in milk chocolate dipped in dark
chocolate they could be topped with
chocolate chips or chopped nuts or
decorative swizzles all sorts of gifts
no matter who you're buying for this
year shari's berries has more than just
berries they have all sorts of new
seasonal offerings as well and here's
what I love you don't have to time your
order based on when you want to deliver
you can just go to Barry's dot-com enter
the code Pakman which will get you the
1999 deal for my listeners and viewers
only and select the delivery date you
said it and forget it and it shows up
guaranteed fresh on the day of your
choice go to Barry's com berr IES
calm click on the microphone in the top
right hand corner and put in my code
Pakman PA que ma n that will get you the
1999 deal delivered on your choice of
dates and it will help to support the
david pakman show